es wäre ein top mann in schwarz und in
weiß
es sind motoren sie wird nicht real
der film heißt der dunkle turm gesagt
auer und ist die verfilmung des haupt
und lieblings und größten werk von
vielen teams
das sind je nach zählweise sieben bis
neun bücher an denen er seit den 70er
jahren gearbeitet hat und daraus einen
film zu machen der noch nicht mal drei
stunden hat und auch keine 3 teile
jedenfalls bis jetzt hat man nicht
gehört also ist konnte eigentlich nur
schief gehen ist es aber gar nicht
draußen gibt es eine andere sagt hauer
ist eine porto fantasy eine portal fand
könnte die geschichte das heißt sie wird
zu dem selben genre wie die unendliche
geschichte von michael ende oder emma
die k5 starker oder auch die zauberer
von aus geschichten von helfern baum und
in allen diesen geschichten geht es um
mindestens zwei wenn ich mehrere welten
die durch irgendwelche porträts portale
türen tore miteinander verbunden sind
und in der dark tower geschichte gibt es
ein zentrum all dieser welt nur das ist
der dunkle turm der sie zusammenhält und
der vor allem das draußen hält was alle
diese welten bedroht nämlich allerlei
monster teuflische böse chaotische
zersetzende zerstörerische tödliche
finstere kräfte für die in diesem film
mexikanischen steht der noch nie
bedrohlich und dreckig war wie in diesem
film und gleichzeitig so eiskalt also
ein wunderbarer schwieriger wird
schlimmer
bekannt dass kommt nicht auf
kein gegengewicht von gegenspieler ist
idris elba einer der besten schauspieler
die moment rumlaufen angespielt worden
den ritter der aber gleich den revolver
mann ist denn in dieser geschichte
treffen nicht nur welten aufeinander
sondern auch loris viel kleinere möchten
mehr das vergangene an dieser welt
diesen versunkenen helden und ritter
umgibt wird in idris elba interpretation
bezogen auf allerlei amerikanische
geschichte auf allerlei tatsächlich
statt gehackte form von unrecht von
gewalt und von dingen für die rache nun
also angemessen wäre
und das ist gerade in krems amerika
natürlich eine ziemlich interessante art
diesen stoff zu behandeln so beschützt
eine und mal gewählt
wenn er fällt virtuelle system ist hat
nicola appel der regisseur dänische
regisseur den man so nah wie hollywood
sachen kennt der hat sich überlegt dass
er das aufeinandertreffen vieler genres
das ja in den urstoff angelegt ist nicht
nur übersetzen muss in filmisches
sondern im grunde das darin enthaltene
filmische wieder freilegen kann also
stimmen die man hört werden zu
klassischen filmen off screen erzählt
stimmen und plötzlich wird einem klar
der kirche text war eigentlich immer so
eine schöne gefühl auf stimme zwischen
ja so ein bisschen eine solche geworden
dass alles über länge haben muss bei
diesem hollywood blockbustern was
natürlich daran liegt dass man die leute
bei all dem angebot von netflix bis man
kann aber 1000 handy kuppen irgendwie
dazu kriegen muss den ganzen abend im
kino zu verbringen also sind die dinger
halt immer länger und immer aufgebläht
und hier hat man sich offenbar überlegt
dass acht bücher von im schnitt 400
seiten in knapp 100 minuten vielleicht
auch passen
das war meiner meinung nach ein fehler
das ende wird dadurch doch wer
zusammengeschoben
vieles ist fast beiläufig was ja eine
leinwand eine richtige leinwände
richtige tiefe der richtige breite eine
richtige ewig verdient gehabt hätte
vielleicht steht ihre welt vor dem ende
[Musik]
lagen menschen stärkt leute die an star
wars leute die an western leute die an
den narnia -film freude hatten und das
kindliche und zusagen naive an dieser
präsentation von es gibt mehr welt las
einen schätzen konnten wollen vielleicht
mal sehen wie das aussieht wenn es
gebrochen ist wenn es erwachsen wird und
es schwieriger wenn es tragisch wenn es
dunkler wird und sie sollten daran gehen
diese wird man in front
[Musik]